GURMEET GOINDI: Welcome friends.
My name is Gurmeet Goindi.
I go by GG.
I'm a product manager on
Google database's product team.
Today I'll be talking
about Bare Metal Solutions.
And how Bare Metal solutions
enable all our enterprises
to bring all their
workloads closer to GCP,
regardless if
their workloads are
written for a collaborative
environment or not.
As you know most of our
enterprises that we work with
are planning to move to a
public cloud environment.
Not only that, Gartner surveyed
a lot of these enterprises.
And they came to a conclusion
that 80% of these enterprises
will move out of their own
operating data centers by 2025.
A lot of you are
already in the journey
of moving out of your
current infrastructure
to a cloud-based environment,
either in a public cloud
setting or in a
private cloud setting.
What are the key migration
and modernization
challenges that most of our
enterprise customers face?
First and foremost, owning and
operating the infrastructure
was a big differentiator
for a lot of the enterprises
20 years ago.
But given the advances that
we have in current silicon
technology, whether it's
computer storage or networking,
the differentiation owning and
operating your infrastructure
brings in is fairly
low to your business.
Secondly, most enterprises
want to embrace
the mythology of developing
applications in cloud,
whether it would be agile
development models, whether it
would be absorbing
new technologies
like artificial intelligence
and AML at a much quicker pace,
or whether it be adopting a very
different way, a DevOps- driven
way of running IT.
But where the
complexity comes in
is how do you marry these
two different concepts?
And this is where
Google Cloud steps in.
Our goal is to
meet you where you
are to be a partner in creating
a migration strategy that
lets you run what you want,
where you want, how you want.
Take your investment
and your current assets
and gradually roll them out
into the best available platform
for them in a public cloud.
Our goal here is to
reduce your risk,
reduce your cost, at the same
time maintaining an agility
to bring your mission
critical workloads as close as
to Google Cloud and
modernize from there on.
We believe this to be
a three step journey.
First, all the
workloads that you
run today which are
not written to run
in the cloud-native
environment, we move them as-is.
By moving them as-is,
we reduce our risk
it takes to come running near
a public cloud environment.
Second, we also
divert your investment
in rather retuning your
existing applications
to run with existing
legacy applications
to run in a public
line environment.
Rather taking that
investment to modernize
those applications to
run natively of the cloud
environment.
Third, in this approach
we believe not only
you can do this at a much
reduced cost with a much
reduced risk, but
at the same time,
we can speed up your journey
to migration to cloud.
And each application will
have its own unique journey.
Each application has its
unique business value
to you as a customer,
and we understand that.
We are here to support the
unique journey per application.
Some of them will lift
and ship from one premise
and stay in cloud as-is.
Some of them will have
to modernize before they
can be lift and ship.
Some of them might
have to be rewritten
in a Cloud-native format.
Google Cloud provides
options for all these parts
with your business goals
being central in our minds.
Let's see how Bare Metal
Solutions play a role
in solving these problems.
But before we go there,
let's try to characterize
what those challenges are.
First, majority of your
mission critical applications
run on [INAUDIBLE] on databases
that are not natively written
for Cloud.
At the same time,
they are the pieces
of applications that run
the core of your business.
They have a very high impact on
how your business runs today.
Second, they are really complex
in their own requirements.
They have been written
over the years.
They have a plethora
of combinations
of off-the-shelves apps
and the apps that work.
They didn't have
homegrown apps that
have contributions of
decades by your engineers
and other engineers.
So migrating such apps or
[? re-migrating ?] these apps
need careful attention.
And that's where
Google Cloud comes in.
In addition, some
of these apps also
might have very stringent
hardware requirements,
the type of hardware that
the particular software
vendors will certify.
And these apps will have
to run on those hardware.
And here, also, Bare Metal
comes in and solves that problem
by providing a certified
hardware to any applications.
But what's the crux
of this challenge
is the interoperability
between your various databases,
various materials where
applications is also
a challenge.
In many cases, a
lot of our customers
don't even have a full
view of how intertwined
their application estate is
with the databases estate.
We cannot modernize just one
without also paying careful
detail attention to the other.
With this [INAUDIBLE]
kept in mind,
we developed Bare
Metal Solutions,
which provides you
the best platform
to migrate all your
legacy and complex apps,
which are difficult
to modernize, as close
as to Cloud.
And then, on a step by
step, gradual manner,
take these applications and
migrate them and modernize them
in a Cloud-native environment
wherever it's possible.
Let's see what Google Bare
Metal Solution offers you.
The key context of
Bare Metal Solutions
is our ability to offer
purpose-built hardware.
A lot of software vendors and a
lot of operating system vendors
have restrictions on
the kind of hardware
their applications can run
on, the kind of hardware that
gives them the best maximum
performance for their databases
of applications.
So what we have done is taken
the latest and the greatest
the silicon industry
has to offer,
married it to what a
certified soft hardware
list for these specialized
vendors would be,
and providing do
you in a setting
which is very close to GCP,
from a latency standpoint.
And you have all
access to all your GCP
services from this purpose-built
hardware solution and vice
versa so that you can move the
data freely between the two.
At the same time,
your applications
that are running in
one way or the other
do not see significant
network latency difference
between the two, as well.
We wrap this around a
Google-managed billing
and support services.
At the same time you
contract with Google
for all your Bare
Metal needs, Google
is the only party
you engage with.
Google, in turn, procures
the latest indicators
the hardware
industry has to offer
and provides that in the
Bare Metal Solution for you.
But you might ask, what
happens to all the investment
that you have already made?
Your existing database
administrators team,
system administrator teams--
what happens to all the
system integrators you have
been working on over the years?
You can bring them as-is
to this environment.
For most [INAUDIBLE],,
this environment
will look like a
new hardware refresh
to what you're already doing.
And you can pick and choose
the pieces of infrastructure
that you need to modernize,
move to Cloud-native
or keep them in Bare
Metal as your application
needs dictates.
Most techie and tech
enthusiasts will say,
I will only believe this when
I see architecture diagrams.
I wanted to walk you through
what architecture looks like
and also open the
possibilities of what
you can do with
this architecture,
and how you can bring in some
of the most complex workloads
you run with this architecture.
Two aspects of this.
On the right side, what you
see is a region extension.
This is a dedicated
hardware hosting
space which is connected with
low latency interconnected
to Google Cloud.
Every entity in Google Cloud
is able to access every entity
in the region extension.
But latency is, in most cases,
less than 1 millisecond.
In some cases, less
than 2 milliseconds.
From an application perspective,
or from a database perspective,
or from a [INAUDIBLE]
perspective, this
all exist and sits in one
large networking construct.
And every application has access
to every other entity running
in this extension.
The three common design
patterns that you see,
first, is in some
cases, customers
wants to run their
packaged apps which
only runs on certain
certified hardware
directly on a bandwidth server.
Second, our customers have
been bringing their database
and keep their
applications in GCP.
And the database comes with
their own internal tooling,
their own internal monitoring,
their own internal best
practices.
They can bring the internal
tooling and the database as-is
under Bare Metal servers,
and connect seamlessly
to the applications
running in these.
The third design pattern
you see the customer
just comes with the database.
In certain areas, we provide
an automation tool package,
which makes the
lifecycle of managing
a database much easier.
This automated tool pack is
an open source contribution
from Google.
You can find that on GitHub.
It's written in Ansible.
It automates the tasks
like provisioning
a database, provisioning
a backup, provisioning
a standby database,
and hence and so forth.
You can pick and choose the
amount of automation you need.
You can modify this
automation if you want some
features to be added from us.
You can request that and
we can do that, as well.
NET(net), we have the capability
to emulate any design pattern
that you have today and
bring it and [INAUDIBLE]
and do some extensions for you.
One key aspect of any database
and deployment is storage.
And we use state of the
art tier one storage.
I'll talk a little bit
more about what all
we do for storage and
operating systems in this.
One key aspect for any
software that runs and needs
an extension is that it follows
the bring your own OS model.
You have [INAUDIBLE]
access to the servers.
access to that database.
Google has no visibility on
what kind of applications
you're running on the
Bare Metal servers.
But we do make the user's
life easier by providing
technologies like snapshots.
So for example, today, we might
be running [INAUDIBLE] in one
of the Bare Metals servers.
And then you probably have
100 Bare Metals servers.
And you probably want to patch
them at some point in time.
Since all these
servers are distressed
and they're all good from a
[INAUDIBLE],, all you have to do
is take a snapshot of
one of the golden images.
And then roll it across
your entire fleet
using the same snapshot.
Hence, lowering the
amount of effort
that you have to spend on
managing an operating system
patch across your fleet.
The same model can be
applied to applications
landing on top of these
operating systems as well.
Let's talk about
what Google provides
as a service in this model.
And what's a customer's
responsibility here?
So in high level construct,
we manage anything that
has to do with the hardware.
So we provide the facilities.
We provide the power cooling.
We provide the
physical security.
We manage the network security.
We make sure all the
break/fix and Smart Hands
is handled by us for you.
At the same time, we
also tune the storage
for best application
performance.
We have worked with industry
standard vendors or industry
leading vendors.
We have taken their
best practices,
combined with the best practices
of all the specialized software
vendors, and implemented that
in the Bare Metal solution.
So when we deprovision
a storage for you,
it has been autotuned
for the next performance
for that database
or the application
that you're planning
to run on top of it.
It takes a big
chunk of work that
needed to be done when you move
from one premise to the Cloud.
Again, on being the
guiding principle here,
the migration to our service
running in Cloud, our goal
is to minimize your
effort required
to do so that you can take that
extra resources in modernizing
those applications.
Everything that runs in
the Bare Metal environment
has access to all
Google services.
And on top of that, Google
takes care of support, billing,
and hardware monitoring tools.
Let's talk about what's
your responsibility.
I touched about the OS
configuration responsibility
earlier.
The same applies to application,
installation, configuration,
and management.
Our automation tool pack helps
in that area for some database
deployment, and database
management, and database
backup, and DR.
At the same time, we're able
to emulate some of the most
complex [? on-premise ?]
networks in our written
extension, which are plugged
into the Google interconnect.
So all your services appear
as if they're running
in a giant network construct.
And they can be accessed across
the interconnect globally.
Second, when it
comes to management,
we provide an SLA-driven
service for infrastructure.
We managed everything that goes
on with the infrastructure.
And anything that goes
on with the application
is managed by our customers.
You can work with
Google Marketplace tools
to help that experience
be more managed.
At the same time, you can use
it your own system integrators
to have the experience
more managed.
For backup and recovery,
we do provide local storage
for your instant
restore backups.
At the same time, the
customers have full flexibility
to have snapshots for their
databases and applications,
as well.
I'll talk about that
in a few minutes.
Before we go discuss the details
of what shapes we provide
and what storage
properties we provide,
let's talk about what your
support experience would be.
This is a Google
Plus party service.
Google is responsible for
this plus level support
and what happens in the
[INAUDIBLE] extension.
Google is responsible for Bare
Metal hardware, the network,
your interconnect, security,
whether it be physical or be it
network security.
We take care of this.
[INAUDIBLE] we provide you
with Smart Hands support.
At the same time, we have a
collaborative support portal
with some enterprise
applications and all operating
system vendors in which
we help our customers
triage operating system
issues and application issues.
At the same time, this is a
three-nines SLA infrastructure,
SLA by Google.
And we are accountable for that.
We also have
solution guides that
enable database workloads
that take the three-nines SLAs
and implement a four-nines
and a five-nines service.
On top of that, in
addition to this,
we also provide
consultative support
for application debugging.
For example, say your
application or database
has a particular issue.
And then you call Google
Support for helping you out
with the issue.
A consultative support
team will look at the issue
and provide you guidance.
What's the best logs
you need to procure?
Was the best metrics you
need to procure so that you
can work actively with
your own software provider
and get to a root cause
sooner than later?
It's a very unique operating
model that we have.
And we have staff, some
of the brightest support
teams, when it
comes to application
support in this regard.
Now, let's take a deep look on
what kind of Bare Metal servers
we provide, what storage
flavors we offer,
and how they all work together
and [INAUDIBLE] habits?
So two broad
category our servers.
Small and medium,
which we think will
be very useful for a single
high-performance apps.
At the same time, as
the dev test systems,
and at the same time as
cluster database systems.
Our large and extra
large machines
do enable mission critical apps
which have that kind of demand
from the infrastructure.
One thing we're
very unique compared
to any other public
cloud vendor is
we adapt the latest and the
greatest silicon technology
very soon as it's released.
At the same time, we offer
full Bare Metal configurations
with the highest memory
to core density ratio.
Why am I talking about
memory to core density ratio?
Memory to core density
ratio is very important
when you talk about
databases and applications.
The higher the ratio, the
more databases and the more
applications you can
run on the same server.
And that has an order
of magnitude impact
on the software licensing
and software support
you have to pay for that server.
Not even to talk about
the management benefits
you get for managing a
few amount of servers
and then a large
amount of servers.
Today we offer Intel
Cascade Lake servers,
which are the latest
that Intel offers today.
And we'll keep our
cadence as and when
the new silicone technologies
come on the horizon.
One very unique offering to
Bare Metals server's solution
is a four socket
112 core machine.
They offer contiguous,
three terabyte memory,
probably ready for the
more stringent database
or application you
have in your enterprise
to be run right
next to Google Cloud
with all the Cloud goodness.
For applications,
what really matters
for the performance is how
well the storage performs,
how vendors storage handles
leading scalability, how well
storage handles
bottlenecks, and how well
storage handle noisy neighbors.
What we have done here is taken
the best practices of our tier
one storage vendor and the best
practices of most operating
systems and application
vendors and incorporated them
in this deployment model.
So when you provision
and [INAUDIBLE] storage
in our environment, it's a
linear performance model.
As you begin to
add more storage,
you get more guarantee
of assured performance
at a very low latency.
You can do hundreds and
thousands of iApps well below 1
millisecond, some things that
transactional databases really
like, and some things that
are lot of deviating struggle
and invest a lot to get
that right level of tuning.
In Bare Metal solutions,
we take care of that
for all of our customers.
A second thing that's very
important for databases
and applications is
ability to restore
your local backups quicker.
For that, we offer
in this construct
are all disk storage, which is
connected within the region.
So you do not have to go
to an object storage access
as you might have to do in other
public clouds, which you can
access really, really
quickly in case of a disaster
or in case of any rollback
issues that you might have.
All these storage
offerings are configured
with automated snapshot.
Automated snapshots are
really helpful for databases
and application test dev.
At the same time, they're very
helpful for data protection
of the environment as well.
Out storage has full
connectivity to GCS.
That's Google Cloud Storage.
You can move backups from
all this to [INAUDIBLE] tier
and [INAUDIBLE] tier,
and GCS and take
full advantage of cost advantage
of a public cloud storage
platform in that regard.
You can also connect these
database and application
servers to applications
running or analytics
running in Google Cloud.
In this case, Google
Analytics and a Google Cloud
will have direct
low latency access
to your transactional databases.
You can run AI, ML models on top
of your transaction databases
in real time to help you
make better decisions.
The possibilities that you
have with this architecture
are endless.
We marry the best
Google Cloud has
to offer with the best silicon
technology that exists there,
and make provide a very
secure low latency offering
all backed behind a Google SLA.
All these servers that we
use here are [? distress. ?]
They all boot from our network
of the network-mounted storage.
Their operating
systems are also hosted
in the network-mounted storage.
There is no data that is
persistent on the servers,
hence makes the lifecycle
management of the server very,
very efficient.
At the same time, the
network between the servers
and the storage is
configured by us.
The network between
the servers and the GCP
is also configured by Google.
And therefore, between the
server and the application tier
is also configured by Google.
How will this architecture
actually look in real life?
And how could your
applications use this?
I'm using a very
simplistic construct.
I'm sure your workloads are
much more complex than this.
And [INAUDIBLE] would be happy
to simplify that [? younger ?]
architectures and then marry
them with our design patterns.
What I'm showing here
is a cluster database
sending in the region
extension, which
is getting replicated using
database-native technology
to another region extension.
So within the region
extension, the cluster database
provides you high availability
build on database's
native capabilities.
At the same time, it uses
Google's networking backbone
to replicate to
another region and make
sure you have the right DR
strategy in place, as well.
You can run your right heavy
transactional workloads
on one region
extension, and you can
run your read-heavy workloads
on the other region extension,
again, using all database
native technologies.
In both of these constructs,
you have full access
to a tool pack,
which you can use
to manage the storage for the
database, install the database,
configure the backup
for the database,
configure the application
do things like patching
prechecks for the database,
using the tools that
are [INAUDIBLE] the tool
pack in your existing
tooling, as well.
At the same time,
the applications
running in Google
Cloud, for them,
the database appears as if
it's on the other applications
of [INAUDIBLE] extension
appears as if they're
running, as if it's in the
Google Cloud construct,
enabling seamless development
of new applications
along on top of your
business critical data.
At the same time,
allowing you a chance
to modernize your architecture
at a piece by piece level,
and at a pace that makes the
most sense for your business
while controlling costs
and managing risk.
The next natural
question will be, hey GG.
I heard a lot about
this technology.
How can I consume this?
So today we are GA in
five regions, globally.
We are available in Frankfurt
and London in Europe.
We are available in Los Angeles
and Virginia in the U.S.
We are live in Sydney
and in [INAUDIBLE]..
So we are complete,
truly global footprint,
and this footprint is
expanding as we speak.
Within this year we will have
four more regions turned on.
One will be in Singapore,
Tokyo, followed by Netherlands,
and Brazil, Sao Paulo.
Develop with this with
one thing in mind,
to meet our customers
where they are,
whether it is their
migration journey,
whether it's their
modernization journey,
whether it's the inability to
lift and shift their workloads,
or whether it be the region
in which they're most
active or most prevalent in.
With that being said, thank
you for taking the time
and listening to this talk.
It's always great to bring
the latest innovation
that we are creating in GCP and
share it with our customers.
So thank you for your time.
And I'll look forward
to talking to you soon.